- [Instructor] In other
videos we introduced ourselves
to the idea of orbitals
and these are various orbitals
in their various subshells
that you could find in
various shells of an atom.
And in this video we're gonna
get a little bit more practice
with electron configuration.
In particular, we're
going to expose ourselves
to the idea of the Aufbau principle.
Now Aufbau comes from German.
It means the building principle.
It's a very useful way
of thinking about electron
configurations past calcium.
Let's just a get little bit warmed up.
What is the electron
configuration of neon?
Pause this video and think about it
and as a hint I will give
you the periodic table here.
All right, well neon has
an atomic number of 10
and if we're talking
about a neutral neon atom
it's gonna have 10 electrons.
And so, the first two will
that fill that first shell.
So we have 1s2 and then, the
next two are going to fill
the 2s subshell in your second shell.
So then you're gonna have 2s2.
And then we have six more
electrons to get to 10
and that's now going to fill
your 2p subshell, so 2p6.
And so what's the order of the subshells
that we just filled?
Well, first we filled
1s, then we filled 2s,
then we filled 2p
and you can also see that in
the periodic table of elements.
In this first row, you're
filling that first shell.
In this second row or this second period,
you are filling that second shell.
Now what's going to happen if
we were to go to say, argon?
So if you're going to go to argon,
what will that electron
configuration look like?
Pause the video and think about that.
Well, we can use the
noble gas configuration
or the noble gas notation.
We could say, all right we're going to be
building off of neon.
So we're gonna have the
electron configuration of neon,
but then we're going to add
electrons into our third shell.
So from neon we would
then add two electrons
into the 3s subshell, 3s2.
And then, to get to 18 electrons,
we're at 12 right now,
we're gonna have six
more that are going to be
in the 3p subshell, so 3p6.
So, on this diagram over here
we went from 2s to 2p to fill up neon
and then as we went to argon
we go to 3s to 3p.
Now what would be the electron
configuration of calcium?
Pause the video and think about it.
All right, well calcium has 20 protons.
So a neutral calcium
would have 20 electrons.
So two more electrons than argon.
So we can build off of argon
and where are those electrons going to go?
And this is where the Aufbau
principle is interesting.
There is indeed a 3d subshell,
but in the case of calcium
instead of those two electrons
being in the 3d subshell,
they end up in the 4s subshell.
So calcium's electron
configuration is the same as argon
and instead of it being
3d2 here on top of that
it goes straight to 4s2.
And so that's why I was
drawing this diagram like this
and you'll often see that
in an introductory chemistry class.
You fill 1s first, no surprises.
You're filling in that first shell.
Then you fill 2s.
Then you fill 2p and you
filled your second shell.
Then you go to 3s, once
again no surprises.
Then you go to 3p.
Now this is the surprise
and why this Aufbau diagram is useful.
For electron configuration purposes,
if you're thinking about
potassium or calcium,
the extra electrons are now
going to go in the 4s subshell.
So now let's think about what
the electron configuration
of the scandium would be.
Pause this video and think about that.
Well scandium has one
more proton than calcium.
It has 21 protons and if it is neutral,
it's also gonna have one more electron
relative to a neutral calcium atom.
And so, it could have a
similar electron configuration.
So we could base it off of argon.
We have two electrons in the 4s subshell,
so I'll write 4s2
and the Aufbau principle
would describe that
and the Aufbau principle,
this little diagram,
would say, all right that
other electron is going to be
in the 3d subshell, so you do 3d1.
And this is indeed an accurate
electron configuration
for scandium.
Now if the Aufbau
principle makes you think
that you're filling 4s first
and then you are starting to fill 3d,
if you were actually
building up a scandium atom,
and that's actually taught
in most chemistry books
and in most classes,
but actually if people start
with the scandium nucleus
that has 18 electrons.
So that would have a positive charge,
when they add that first electron
it actually does not go to 4s.
It goes to 3d.
So this electron actually
gets added first.
If you're actually
thinking about building.
But I don't want to confuse you too much.
In this video we're just thinking about
the electron configuration
and for that Aufbau can be very useful.
Now for electron configuration purposes,
3d, you then go to 4p, and
then you then go to 5s,
and that's why you might
see this type of a diagram,
once again, in your traditional
first year chemistry books.
So the big takeaway here
is the Aufbau principle
that you'll learn, this type of diagram,
it's useful for electron configuration
and it might be useful to think about it
as you're building these
atoms electron by electron,
but if you really want
the precise accurate truth
once you get beyond calcium
it gets a little bit more complicated.
Now one other thing that
I want you to appreciate
based on what we just learned is patterns
in the periodic table of elements.
So for which elements are we
building out our S subshell?
Well, you could see that
for all of these elements
right over here,
these first two columns,
we're building out our S subshell.
Now it looks like
something is missing there.
Is there something else that
builds out our S subshell?
Well, from that point of
view we could actually think
of helium as being right over here
'cause helium, we're
building out that 1s subshell
and because of that all of
these elements right over here,
we say that they are in the S block.
Now, which elements are
building out their P subshells?
Well, all of these
elements right over here
are building out their P subshells
or have it fully built out.
And because of that,
all of these elements,
we call these the P block.
And these elements in the
middle right over here,
scandium is one of them,
they are called the D block.
Now one reason why folks might
have called it the D block
is if you really imagine
the Aufbau principle
as building up atoms,
it might be tempting to say,
oh well we're building
in the fourth row here,
we're building the 3d subshell
or in the fifth row here we're
building the 4d subshell.
Now we now know that
that actually isn't true,
but from electron
configuration point of view
it can appear that way
and so that's why it is called the D block
and I will leave you there.